hey youtubers is Charlie in an honour of
Doctor Who doing Robin Hood this week I
wanted to do my top 10 favorite
fictional and historical characters from
the show I tried to limit myself on the
pool of people that I picked from like
either people that the doctor has
actually met or full-on characters in
episodes real quick reminder in the
giveaway - it's still running or if
you're just finding me for the first
time I'm doing a weekly Doctor Who
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video or on my review so since
there really aren't any spoilers from
episode 3 in this you guys don't have to
worry about that if you haven't seen the
episode but starting with number 10
Stevie Wonder from good man goes to war
the doctor snatched Stevie Wonder to
play for rivers birthday and took both
of them back to 1814 it's implied it was
the Matt Smith doctor but it's hard to
tell since River talks about meeting
several of his faces I think one of my
favorite River birthday references
though was when she talked about like
the whole different birthday when there
were two doctors I'm sure the doctor
paid Stevie a very generous fee though
but I kind of wonder which Stevie he
picked like was it young Stevie Wonder
or old Stevie Wonder moving on to number
9 though Sigmund Freud from curse is a
black spot this was just a name drop
Freud was one of those real-life
historical figures though that showed up
all across Doctor Who and the expanded
material just because he's such a
notable figure but a couple of different
versions of the doctor have sat on his
couch and given the psychosexual nature
of his work we can only imagine what
their conversations must have been like
I feel like a really good anniversary
box said in the future would be like
Freud's data file on the doctor like
just as like a funny Easter egg if any
of your real-life psychology students
maybe you can confirm this but I heard
that in real life the actual Sigmund
Freud felt like people ended up twisting
a lot of the things that he said in a
lot of his research meaning that what he
originally intended for psychoanalysis
to be ended up turning into something
way way different
but moving along number 8 William
Shakespeare from Shakespeare Code
another really big recurring historical
character from the Canon he's been part
of at least four TV stories not
including Shakespeare code but the David
Tennant episode made him a much bigger
part of the plot it's a very Magic based
story so it's also a lot of fun cuz I'm
a big fan of magic I love the way they
play with the myth of Shakespeare versus
the reality I mean they do that with a
lot of historical figures but this time
it was just hilarious
everybody shut your big fat mouth
just sounds so much better coming from
the mouth of the bard the episode was
actually written by Gareth Roberts who's
written a whole bunch of other Doctor
Who episodes he actually wrote I think
it's episode 6 of series 8 right now
moving along Houdini
from Planet of the OOD I loved Donna and
the Tenth Doctor such a great buddy cop
flick when those two work together
Houdini was just really uses a joke in
this story several different doctors
mentioned medium and learning escape
tricks but Planet of the OOD was funny
because it was a big joke on how the
doctor one either couldn't completely
figure out Houdini's handcuffs trick or
the trick was just useless because the
handcuffs were too futuristic Donna is
actually one of the few companions that
I can tolerate ripping on the doctor all
the time it just feels so natural coming
from her mouth I know Clara's kind of
tried to make fun of Capaldi a little
bit but it's a very different vibe but
moving on to number six Leonardo da
Vinci he's been featured in the comics a
lot but on the show he's mostly been
used in reference the Sixth Doctor did
have a business card that read da Vinci
and the Fourth Doctor did talk about him
a lot during city of death
a lot of you guys reference city of
death whenever I was asking you for your
favorite historical character references
the other really funny thing going on
with episode 3 right now robot a short
is that Tom Reilly played da Vinci in da
Vinci's demons I'm not current with that
show right now like I don't do videos
for it but it's a cool coincidence
crossover interactions like this are
really really common in British TV
though just because projects tend to run
for shorter periods of time and there's
not the issue that you have with
different networks competing for a
different talent but moving on to number
5 Winston Churchill and so many
different things
Ian McNeice is probably one of my
favorite character actors usually when
he's playing villains but it's really
hard to forget his Winston Churchill
just another one of those real-life
historical figures that's so famous he
just ends up being parodied a lot not
that I think that Doctor Who version of
him was poking fun too much I think the
series 6 finale was the most fun use of
Churchill the episode is just so crazy
in general that you kind of forget about
him at a certain point but just the idea
of Churchill as the Holy Roman Emperor
is so funny I think that says a lot
about what Moffat thinks the Churchill
thinks about himself like Churchill
would see himself as a holy roman
emperor we're not meant to dig too deep
though but you do start to wonder how he
was able to depose all the previous
emperors but the way they collapsed time
in that up
was really confusing but moving out to
number four Dracula and son of the
Dragon the big finished story it's a
fifth doctor story about glad the
Impaler the doctor travels back to 1462
and it's more of a Vlad Dracula story
than a traditional vampire story I'm
always a big fan of Dracula stories in
general that just aren't straight up
retellings of the Bram Stoker myth
there's actually even a new Luke Evans
Dracula movie coming out that's kind of
a prequel it's like a Vlad Tepes movie
in the Big Finish story he's played by
James Purefoy from the following on to
number three Queen Nefertiti from
dinosaurs on spaceship I love the ship
that developed between her and Rupert
graves from Sherlock so many fandoms in
that episode including Harry Potter one
of the best moment she had though it was
when she met Amy and asked her if she
was also a queen I feel like Amy kind of
let that go to her head from there after
like from there after she kind of
thought of herself as a little bit more
of a queen in like the most adorable way
I would say that most if not all female
companions on Doctor Who are Queen
material would it be so funny though if
like on all the BBC casting sheets for
potential future female companions it
said you know must be able to play Queen
I feel like one of the reasons they
chose Nefertiti in that episode was
because Cleopatra had already been done
so much there are only a handful of
notable ancient Queens to pick from I
would say Catherine the Great is
probably one of the bigger ones they
haven't done yet I do kind of wonder if
they didn't use her just because the
Cold War was going on during a lot of
classic who the singer Fox's is actually
gonna be in mummy on the Orient Express
she's gonna be playing a singer in the
episode but everyone keep your eyes
peeled for more Cleopatra references
moving on to number 2 Hitler from let's
kill Hitler so this episode was made
after inglorious bastards did that crazy
version of Hitler and the Hitler
downfall movie the one with the scene of
Hitler going insane in case you missed
it it was parody to infinity but the
funny thing that Moffat did in this
episode was basically reduced Hitler to
window dressing like he almost had a
non-speaking part I just love that they
made one of the most infamous villains
in modern history window dressing in a
River Song story of course it totally
makes sense the crazy melody pond would
show up in a Hitler episode but finally
my number one favorite historical
character Vincent van Gogh he's my
favorite mostly because the episode
Vincent in the doctor just in general is
an emotional touchstone for the Matteson
Thera and for me personally but it's
also because the way it tied things back
to the doctors future I mean most of the
episode is spent trying to relate genius
in this understandable way like the
psychology of genius and what it is
about Vincent that's broken him part of
the point I think it made was that you
know T's isn't really supposed to make
sense just because you have to be genius
to fully understand it or a madman in a
box but you do have two geniuses one
with the blue box and one with the brush
in canvas both completely unable to
change their futures
they couldn't alter Van Gogh's timeline
and all the terrible things from the
doctors future that we've learned about
so far will probably still end up
happening at some point for example I
think the pocket universe solution
during the 15th anniversary is just a
stopgap I think eventually the Time
Lords will come out and the time war
will start again it's gonna be really
interesting to see how the show deals
with that right now I think the only
solution to avoid you know potential
time war is for the writers to keep
Gallifrey inside the pocket universe
I do think Capaldi is gonna find it
eventually but I don't think that
they're gonna rush to bring it back into
normal space I think that part of the
reason they saved it in the 50th from a
production standpoint at least was so
that someday they'd be able to do Time
Lord stories again but not right away
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments who's your favorite
fictional or historical figure on Doctor
Who and do you want to see them bring
Gallifrey back like full-on Time Lords
back before Capaldi leaves in case you
didn't see my earlier videos he is
signed on for series 9 it's Jenna
Coleman that's still undecided or at
least unannounced if she already has
made up her mind I'm still working on my
Q&A for tomorrow be sure to subscribe to
get it there's still plenty of time to
ask questions for me to include in that
so maybe you guys have actually had some
really good theories about the promised
land so far but right now you can click
here to get that Q&A I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to get my episode 3
review thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you